それで仏教の世界に入ります
今までほとんど俗世間のお話です
心の科学という仏教は
この性格を判断することになると
個人の性格を判断することになるとプロです
だから皆様には専門以外の話になるかもしれません
もうできるだけ一般の方々にわかるように
上部だけ今日紹介しますけど
まず資格 これ医学部に入ることと同じ
もう誰でも入るわけじゃないんですからね
資格があるんです 人の性格を分析するために
誰にでも他人の性格を分析して判断することは
仏教は認めていないんです
簡単に罪を犯す人 無知な人
道徳を重んじる人 智慧あるでしょうね
智慧がある人などを大雑把に知った方が自己の安全になるので
そこまでですと だからあまり性格分析しないで
大雑把でいいんだよと
あんた方には 例えば医学はお医者さんはプロですけど
しかし 我々も自分の身の安全のために
いくらか医学的な知識を持たなくちゃいけないでしょ
だからといって 自分で自己診断して薬まで買って飲むっていうのはとんでもない話でしょうね
私も腎臓が悪いんだから
この薬飲もうとかね それは専門家に任せた方がいいんですよ
でもそれ前に まあ肝臓に悪いもの
腎臓に悪いものは大雑把で理解して身を守ればいいんです
性格の場合でも あの人はちょっと罪を犯す人やとちょっと知った方がいいじゃないんですかね
あの人は無知だと あの人はすごく道徳道徳を重んじるんだと
あの人には知恵があるんだと
頭がいいんだと それ大雑把ですよ
頭がいいと思った人も
必ずしも 24時間が頭がいいわけじゃないんです
まあ大雑把に言えば頭いい人
罪を犯す人も 朝から晩まで罪を犯すわけないでしょうに
しかし もう罪を犯す回数はちょこちょこっとあるんだと
そういうふうに大雑把で知った方がいいということなんです
差別は罪なので それにもよく注意しなくちゃいけないんです
あの人はちょっと悪いことばっかりしてるんだ人だなと思っていいんだけど
差別してはいけないんです
だから嫌な人間だとかね
裁かなくちゃいけないんだとか
あれこれと言ってはならんです
差別することが罪になるんです
自分も他も幸福になる程度で理解しておく
何のために人の性格を大雑把にわかるのかというと
幸福になるために 例えば
もうそっちではなくて
たまたま悪いことをする人がいて
自分の知り合いで まあそれわかってね
あんた気をつけた方がいいんじゃないの？とかね
あんた気をつけなければ
ちょっと仲良くしてあげることできませんよとかね
そこで相手もなんとなく罪を犯すことはちょっと管理するでしょうね
そこで差別してはそれできないんですよ
あんたあっち行きなさい
我々違いますから 性格悪いんだから
言うとその人は一生性格は良くならないでしょうね
あんた仲間なんですけど
そっち悪いことするんだから困ったもんですね
これは とかね ちょっと気をつけましょうよと
そうすると仲良くもっと仲良くできるでしょうというと
それは差別じゃないですよね
そうすると その人は幸福になる
自分は人の役に立ったことになる
そのために性格を知っておくんです
性格を完全に判断できるのは
正覚者であるブッダのみというのは仏教の定石です
資格ない 資格がないのは当たり前なんです
ブッダにしか人の性格を判断する能力がないんです
知識になりますので 釈尊の特別な能力の一部を学んでいます
あんまり役に立たないんですけど
ただ知識だけ これは難しいんだから
もうパーリ語だけにしたんです
アティータナガタパッチュパンナーナン
カンマサマーダーナン
ターナソウ ヴィパッサナー
ヤタールーパンパジャナーナって
お釈迦様は自分で言うんですね
私はこの生命の中で獅子のごとく吠えていますよと
神様のごとく堂々と自分に喋ってますよと
何も怖いものはないんだと
なぜならば 私はこれを知っていますよと
アティータというのは過去
アナガタっていうのは将来
パッチュパンナっていうのは現在
あの仏教は過去現在未来と言わないんです
あるいは未来現在過去とは言わないんです
時計の順番に 過去と未来と現在というんです
なんで分けてるの？過去と未来というのは存在しないんです
現在は存在するんです
そこで とにかく三世にわたるカンマサマーダーナ行為について知ってますよと
生命があらゆる行為をする
喋ったり 歩いたり 食べたり
いろんな行動し 考えたりするでしょうに
それが厳密にありのままに知ってますよと
一切の生命の行為について
これからヤタールーパンパジャナーナありのままに
知ってますよと 行為っていうのは業のことなんです
あれ 行為に結果が出ますからね
一個ずつ知ってるんです
このような行為にはこの結果
このような行為にこの結果と
例えば人に向かってこの野郎と言ったら
それ行為でしょ？どんな結果でしょうかと
それはこの野郎という単語で判断できませんよ
だからこの人はこの野郎と言ったことにはこういう結果だよと
この人の場合はこういう結果だよと
あの人の場合はこういう結果だよと
こういうふうに区別していることができます
例えばこの野郎っていうことは怒っていうこともできるし
その場合は怒りの行為なんですよ
あまりにも愛着があって
かわいくて言う場合もあります
その場合は欲でしょうし
だから業の結果が違うんです
言った言葉は同じですけど
ただ 口癖で人を呼ぶ言葉として使う人もいますからね
その場合はもう口癖だからあまり業にならないんですね
同じ言葉なのに あるいはその人を育てたいんです
躾したいんです 心配しているんです
だからこの人にはこう言った方がわかるんだよと理解した上で
この野郎と言った場合は
慈しみの行為だから善行為なんです
だから同じ言葉にしたっても
結果はバラバラなんです
そういうものをお釈迦様は知り尽くしてますよと 2
番目 サッバッタダーミニパ
ヤタブータンパジャーナ
生命が輪廻転生するんですよ
神にもなるし 餓鬼道にも落ちるし
地獄にも行くし 畜生でも生まれ変わるし
人間界にも来るし この太陽系から飛んで別なところに生まれ変わったりもする
いろいろあります それで生命がどこでどういうふうに生まれるかって
その法則はしっかり知っている
輪廻の中で いかなる場所にでも生まれ変われるならば
その法則を知っていますよ
生き方も知っていますよ
例えばもう神になりたいと言ったなら
お釈迦様は方法を知っています
餓鬼道に落ちたいんだけど
お釈迦様 私は だったらあんたこうしなさいと教えてあげませんだけど
まあ言うことはできます
ですから ある夫婦が死後も一緒になりたいんだと言ったら
それだったらあなた方にはこういうこういうこういうことをしなさいと
そこをその智慧がお釈迦様にあるんですね
3番目 サッターナンナーナーディムッティカーナンヤタブータンパジャーナティ
これが性格のことなんです
いろいろ生命の方向性と好み
しっかり知ってますと
ナーナーディムッティカっていうのは
人が成長する過程でどんな方法
どんな道はよろしいのかと
例えば子供たちの場合
大きな問題でしょう 自分の将来何すればいいかとわからないでしょうに
我々は自分のことなのに
自分の将来の道がわからないんですよ
将来どんな道を選ぶべきかということは
それにつけたら お釈迦様ならどんな生命に対しても
君はこの道で歩めと言えるんです
それ知ってるんです これはアディムッタという一単語で仏教でまとめています
だから性格と方向性と隠れている能力
あるいは発展できる能力
それ全部まとめて知っているんです
パラサッターナンパラプッガラナンインドリヤパローパリヤッタンヤタブータンパジャーナティ
他人のこと インドリヤパローパリヤッタという単語があります
インドリヤパローパリヤッタ
これなかなか訳しにくいもの
インドリヤっていうのはこの鬼魂という仏教用語がありますけど
また逆に言えば能力みたいなもんでもありますけど
どこまで熟しているのか
どこまで低いなのかと
それは知っています 例えば智慧というものがありますね
智慧っていうのはいくらかできているか
全然できていないか ものを理解する能力
ああ この人ならできている
この人は全くダメ  0 それ知っています
これは本当に言えば 現代で言えば能力のことなんですね
この能力は発展しているか
発展する能力たくさんありますよ
このグラフを知っています
だからお釈迦様ならどんな人でも導くんです
導いてあげることはできます
随分簡単に 智慧の方が 0 だったら
そこを開発するようにしてあげる
理解能力ない人なら まあそこはなんとか
だったらこういう風な方法でやりましょうと
人格向上をさせてあげます
皆様よく知っている物語あるでしょう
チューラパンタカの物語
日本語でパンダカパンダカと言うでしょ
あの勉強できないんですね
いわゆる記憶力はないんですね
物覚えはできないんです
それちょこっとした病気で
ダイレクシスという病気はあるでしょう
ヨーロッパ アメリカでも
24文字しかないのに文字読めないというね
日本語の人から見れば大変なことでしょうね
ローマ字読めないという
中国人から見ると考えられないでしょうね
でもそういう病気があるんですよ
で あれちょっと頭が悪いわけじゃないんです
どうもなんか文字を組み合わせた読めない
それわかると あ この子はそういう欠点を持ってるんですから
どうすればこれ直せるのかとすぐわかりますからね
私も何人かにそうやって
まああ 文字読めない子だなとわかって
もう大体 30 分で 直してあげたんです
だからそこを発見すると
もう直してあげることはできます
なんだこの野郎 なんか言ったらわかるのかって怒っちゃうともうダメなんですよ
ですから このインディリパロパリアッタっていうのは
そういう様々な能力の上下
熟しているか まだ未熟なのかということが
お釈迦様が知り尽くしてますから
誰にも怖いものはないんだと堂々と語っているんだ
挑戦できるなら 私の言葉に挑戦してみなさいというすごい態度なんだよ
お釈迦様 というわけで
業の法則 輪廻の法則 心の能力などをありのままに知って
その上限りなく過去を見られる能力が必要ですよ
性格を分析するために
では 皆様にあるならば
堂々もう自信を持って人の性格を判断してください
限りなく過去を見られる能力があったりとかね
業の法則を知っているならば
輪廻の法則は自分でちゃんと知っているならば
人の性格はこんな性格だと言えます
なぜそこまで必要なのかというと
私たちの性格は無知なる過去から築いたことの結果でもあります
それで全部じゃないんですね
一部だけ今 今世で機能しているんです
今私が持っている能力も
過去でいろいろ磨いたものです
しかし 過去でいろんな能力を磨いたんですけど
一部今機能しているんです
それで下手なところも同じで
だからそうやってずっと見ておかないと正しい性格は言えないんですよ
ですから チュッラパンダカさんが何一つ覚える能力はないんです
しかし お釈迦様は性格で言ってます
この人はバカじゃないんだと
基本は熟しているんだ
ただ物を覚えたくないだけ
それにも過去には原因があるんだ
覚えたくないんじゃなくて
その能力は今世でついてない
だからそれはどうでもいいことで完成させてやるぞとお釈迦様はちょっと布を引いてきてあげて
これは洗ってくださいと
ということで 一言教えてあげて綺麗にしますと
で 本人がそれもう揉んだりする
揉んだところで綺麗になるどころか逆になってしまったんですね
汚くなっちゃったんです
そこで智慧が動き出しちゃって
瞑想して 1 日にして悟ったんです
その人の叔父様が 3ヶ月間の行一つ 4 行ですよ
覚えさせようと思って
ダメで あんた家に帰ってくださいと
仏道 あんたには務まりませんと破門されたんですよ
そういう人がお釈迦様が朝見つけて
昼間になってくると もう完全に悟っているんです
それはこれできるんだからなんですよ
だからこのたやすいことじゃないんで
人の性格分析するっていうことは
ただ単に人間の性格を明確に決定的に知るために
ですよ で 人を判断する流れという注意として理解するべきですと
なんでここまで仏教はここまで知って何するのかで
ただ単に人間の性格明確に決定的に知るだけ
お釈迦様はあそこまで能力使っていかなる人間にも神々にもない値しない
超越した能力を身につけて何なさったかというと
人の性格を判断するだけ
なんかもったいないんですけど
だからお釈迦様は私はこれぐらいの能力があって
あなた方の性格を判断していますよということで
裏読んだら何でしょうかね
我々は決して人の性格を判断してはいけないということ
仏教は論理倫理的な立場で分析するんです
それからお釈迦様は教えていますよ
弟子たちに 皆様にではないんです
あの弟子たちに 人の性格はどうやって分析して理解するのかということをかなり教えていた
かなり量があるんです
人を解脱へ導くために
心に潜んでいる能力のありさまを探すんです
仏教の目的は慈しみの目的で
とにかく人を解脱へ導かなくちゃいけない
罪から脱線させなくちゃいけない
幸福にしてあげなくてはいけない
煩悩ない心を作って 平安の心を作れるように押し押してあげなくちゃいけないんだよと
そのためには性格を知らなきゃ無理だと
だから性格を知っておくんです
それで弟子たちにはその能力がないんだから
お釈迦様の教えの中からいくらか学んで
そこから判断するんです
それで倫理的ということを覚えておいてください
この会社のためじゃないんです
死ぬまで夫婦仲良くするための性格分析じゃないんです
ですから 俗世間的な目的はないんです
あくまでも倫理的な目的
性格分析するんです 人のすべては
業によって定めるので
善悪基準で性格を間違っていますね
性格判断するのは普遍的です
いろいろ単語を抜けています
だからこの 言いたいのは
我々のすべてが業の結果なんですよ
顔形も体も健康も寿命も髪の色も
髪は薄いか厚いか もう何でも結局は業の結果なんですよ
だからこういうふうに結果あるんだぞという基準で性格を判断した方が合ってます
俗世間にもそれが役に立ちます
俗世間にも役に立つことは立ちます
これから性格は大雑把でこういう風に分析するんです
ラーガチャリタという 1番目
これ柱になる性格 はっきりとそういう性格はあるとは思わないんです
ものすごい複雑です ラーガチャリタというのは欲
喜び 楽しみが中心的な人
楽しいものだったら まあすぐもう
それにはかかっている
欲中心ですね  2番目はドーサチャリタ
怒り中心で いつでも何でも嫌な目で見る
批判的な目で見る 何か見ると何か欠点がないのかと
何か一言も言えないのかという目で見る性格なんですね
怒りっぽいということもあります
モーハチャリタは無知が中心
無知が中心ということは
皆様にあまりわからないかもしれません
あんまりこの無関心型というかね
興味を持てない性格 飽きっぽい人と微妙に違うんですよ
飽きっぽいとかなんとかいうのは我々の判断でしょ
あれはあまり仏教的には使わないんです
で 粘り強いとかね もう飽きっぽいとか
いろいろ俗世間での単語ありますけど
仏教ではそういう倫理的な立場で分けても
なぜならばこれではもう悪
悪いということをはっきりしていますからね
無知な性格の人っていうのは
あんまり物事に興味を持たない
興味を持ってもらうためにはものすごい苦労をしなくちゃいけないんです
例えば子供っていうのは結構飽きっぽいですけど
興味を持たないわけじゃないんです
もう次から次へと興味が変わっているだけで
それにサッダアチャリと信が中心的な
信っていうのは信仰の信なんですけど
何でしょうかね  すごい簡単に納得しやすいというか
あまりガチャガチャなんでなんで？なんて
ああ そうですか よくわかりましたと
それで素直に 言うとおりやったりとかね
人の話を素直に聞いたりとかね
しかし こちらにサッダという善良い方の単語を使っています
ですから このどちらかというと良い方を選ぶんですね
素直で人の話を聞くんだからといって
悪いことも素直に否定するんです
私はそういうことはやりませんだからとかね
いいことを言ってあげると
あ そうですか ではやりますと
という 単純ですね そこでヴィパッサナーチャリティー思考観念が中心ですね
とにかく考える あれやこれや
6番目はブッダチャリティー
智慧が中心 すぐ発見するんです
あ これだ これ これこうでしょうとかね
この考える人はあんまり発見しないんですよ
考えて考えて考えて それで終わりますけど
ブッダチャリタっていうのは
すぐあ こういうことだ
ですから考えることはないんです
もうわかったんだから
数学の質問だったら もう思考型はもう紙たくさん無駄に使って
もうもうそこで論じるは論じるは論じるは論じるは
まあそれで時間が終わってしまっちゃって
結論に達してないんです
ブッダ型の人は難しい数学問題ですけど
こういうことでしょって一句で書いてしまったと
で 考えてないんですね
だからすごく違うんですね
はい それがわかることにしたっても
我々は何型とどうやって知るのかっていうこと
そこはすごく大変なんです
それで仏教でいうのは
結構時間かけてその人を観察しなさいと
です それで悪いことに
この 1番目の 1番目のラーガチャリタと 4番目のサッダーチャリタは性格似ているのです
ラーガ欲型の人っていうのは
部屋はすごく綺麗に整理整頓して
ポスターでも貼って花も立てて
もう塵一つもなく まあ人が住んでるところかと疑問になるぐらいの
もう何でもちょっと掃除でも頼んだらもう綺麗にやってやったりとかね
丁寧に そこでどうしても美しいものに惹かれてしまって
美しくないものがあっても
何とかしてそれを美しく見えるようにしたりとか
で 仕事なんでもすごい綺麗に整理整頓して美しくするとか
それでサッダーチャリタに仕事を頼んだらまた同じなんですよ
だから行動パターン見ると同じですけど
指導者がこの人はラーガチャリタかサッダーチャリタかということは
指導者にとっては大変なんです
判断するのが お釈迦様だったら何のことなく判断するのに
そこで怒り方っていうのは
ガチャガチャガチャこれはここだからもうダメでしょうね
今日は雨が降ってるんだから
どうにもならんでしょうとかね
もうしゃべるわ しゃべるわ
しゃべるわ そこでヴィパッサナーと同じことで
今日は仕事があるんだからと言ってもね
もう今日は雨が降ってるでしょうに
あるいは突然雨が降る可能性もあるでしょうに
だから気をつけなくちゃいけない
一応中止した方がいいんで
同じこと言っちゃう では
そんな簡単に中止しようと思っちゃっても
やっぱりせっかく決めたことだから
やっぱりまた逆のことを言うんです
だからどちらでしょうかと
結論ないんですね それで怒り方の人も思考型の人も性格似ているんですよ
すごい難しいんです 次に
このモーガチャリタ無知
小心な人は無関心的でしょ
そうですね ということで
それで知恵のある人も別にもう知ってるんだからね
いちいちいちいちそれ調べるとかじゃないんでしょうに
でもわからないんですよ
しかし 単純ではないということで
実際は基本性格が噛み合って
自分の性格が成り立つのですよ
本当はこんな明確に 6色に人間は分けられません
性格かみ合ってるんです
だって何万円？無限の過去から積み重ねたものでしょ
このコンピューターに文字入れちゃうと
いろいろいらん文字が頭がいいんですから
いらん文字も入れてくれますけどね
それは無視してください
いらんも言ったって円の記号しか入れませんだからね
まあ金欲しがってるでしょうね
どちらでも円やと それよりは
で こういうふうに噛み合われ
噛み合われますよ ラーガ
ラーガ チャリティ 欲 欲型の欲型
それだったらはっきり分かれます
もうもうスケベとかね
もういろいろ言うでしょ
で ラーガドーサ 欲型なんですけど
怒り入っていて あの女
あんまり女欲しいんだけど
あれ髪型ね ちょっとあの人唇色が何あれとかね
本当はもう好き欲なんですが
ちょこちょこっと批判したり見る
それでラーガのドーサチャリタ
ラーガのモーホチャリタ欲があるんだけど
無関心 な態度を取る で
ラーガサッダ欲があるんだけど
また悪いことはしたくないという
もうあっちこっち無差別にナンパするんじゃなくて
すごく丁寧に道徳があって
決まりが守って親いうことをちゃんと聞いて
まあナンパするとか で
ラーガヴィパッサカ 私はこの女性に決めたのはこうだから
だからあれあれものすごく
で 言ってることすごく矛盾してますよ
よくよく喋りますからとかね
よく人の話を聞きますから
喋る人は人の話聞きませんだけどね
そういう風にとにかく論理ばっかり言う
あるいはラーガ ブッディック
欲があるんだけど ブッダ智慧を働かせて欲を満たしてもらうと
ですから ラーガ中心は 6種類になっちゃうんですよ
それで全部 36種類になっちゃうんです
大変です 表向きいろいろ役を演じる演じるが
人の心色の色を発見するべきです
そこで我々は表向きで怒ったり
女を褒めてあげたりとかいろいろしますけど
心色はどんな色なのかと
そこが性格なんですね
あの小学生とか幼稚園児の間ではよくあるでしょうに
まあ男の子の心理しかほとんど知りませんだけど
まあ男の子は好きな女の子ができちゃうと蹴ったりするでしょうに
本を取ったり だから女の子が悪い子で
こうやと嫌な人やと思ったりするんですけど
本当はそうじゃなくて
その女の子のこと好きなんですね
そこで表現する方法を知らないんですね
とにかく自分の方向に興味を持ってほしい
だから その女の子の本を持ってどこか行ったの
女の子は泣きながら後ろから行かなくちゃいけないんですね
結果は最悪なんですけど
だから この表向きで意地悪な子だなと判断するんじゃなくて
大人は君はあの子のこと好きでしょうと
好きだったらそういうことをしないで一緒に遊びましょうとか言った方がいいんじゃないのかと教えてあげた方がいいんですよ
しかし 子供のくせにいじめの型の子供もいますよ
だからちっちゃな幼稚園児が女の子をいじめる
もう一人が女の子をいじめると言ったってのも同じというわけじゃないんです
表で演じることの裏に本人の色があるんです
そこを発見して指導しないと大変なことになるんです
それはビスディマッガってテキストにあります
ビスディマッガテキストにあるのは
この瞑想を指導する前という
これこれこれ勉強しなさいと
相手にどんな瞑想を教えるのかという前に
随分きめ細かく書いてあります
それからアビダンマという仏教の心理学
本 7冊あります そこでこの 4番目をテキストプッグラパンニャッティっていうんですね
名前を このタイトルは直訳すると性格の認定っていう意味なんです
アビダンマ論っていうのは膨大なんですけど
それで本 1冊性格認定に使ってます
あまり役に立たないと思います
仏教的な話だからね そのすぐお釈迦様が語られた人格の種類をすべてまとめたテキストですが
厳密に修行の角度から分析しているんです
だから現代心理学に役に立つ
ようにと読んでもそれほどデータ取れないかもしれません
取りたければ我々から学ぶしかないんです
我々は知ってます これ俗世間にどう適用できるか
仏教の世界ではどう適用するのかっていうこと
お釈迦様は大体は人っていうのはこの 4つに分けたり
かなり 4つに分けることするんですよ
時々 5つに分けたり  6つに分けたりとかね
いろんな時 例えば怒りの場合でも瞬時に激怒する人
しかし すぐ冷めると ゆっくり怒るんだけど
なかなか冷めない人 ゆっくり怒るんですけど
すぐ冷める人とかね そういうふうに怒り一つの人っていうのもいろいろ分けるんですよ
それから人の能力も あの理解能力の場合でも
言っただけでわかる人
言ってから分析して説明するとわかる人
何回何回 何回何回言ってゆっくり理解させていただける人
いくら言ってもダメな人
それで 4つに分けるんですよ
そういういろんなカテゴリーがあるんです
それはアングッテルニカヤという本にたくさん出ています
中部経典にもあります
そういうのは全部このアビダルマテキストで全部揃ってます
このテキストで第1章で人格が 54種類に分けてます
まあそれは皆さんにそれほど関係ないというもの
阿羅漢とかね ブッダとか全部入ります
阿羅漢という人格者もいて
阿羅漢になろうとする人格者もいるんだと
不還果という人格者もいて
不還果になろうという人格
そこそういうところもありますから
我々に関係ないものはたくさんありますけど
関係あるものもあります
まあ一応まあ性格っていうのは分析っていうのはそんなもんで
すごい難しいという それですから
ちょっと解説してみます
というか ちょっと休憩します